le choix qui est fait par le
gouvernement et qui est proposé bien sûr
au Parlement c'est c'est le choix de
consolider l'organisation du contrôle de
la sûreté nucléaire et la
radioprotection en la rassemblant au
plus haut niveau d'indépendance par
rapport au gouvernement puisqu'il s'agit
effectivement vous l'avez dit de
fusionner l'ensemble des activités de
l'URSS avec celle de la SN mais au sein
de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
indépendante donc c'est une garantie par
rapport à votre question sur le risque
de perte de confiance dans le contrôle
de la sûreté c'est la garantie qui est
apportée à travers ce projet très fort
par le gouvernement c'est d'aligner le
standard sur le plus haut niveau de
dépendance par rapport au gouvernement
et par rapport aux exploitants c'est le
cas de l'ASM et lorsque l'on regarde les
deux organismes à essai IRSN nous avons
aujourd'hui la même raison d'être c'est
à dire que la seule mission de l'IRSN
comme la seule mission de la SN c'est la
protection des personnes et la
protection de l'environnement